plus
bonsoir à tous et merci de choisir
france 3 la chaîne des régions pour
revivre ce premier tour des élections
régionales en bourgogne franche comté
19h aller 4771 bureaux de vote de nos
deux régions sont donc fermés à cette
heure-ci tout au long de la soirée
nous irons dans les huit départements en
direct pour vous donner elle les
résultats au plus près de chez vous
bonsoir ou dans un bon soir arnaud
bonsoir à tous pour ce scrutin inédit
france 3 met en oeuvre un dispositif
exceptionnel tout au long de la soirée
nous allons vous proposer des reportages
des réactions également mais aussi des
analyses avec nous sur ce plateau nos
deux journalistes politiques jérémy
chevreuils et lilian melet et puis
également à nos côtés elle a besoin qui
tout au long de cette soirée bien va
nous raconter ce qui se passe sur le fil
des réseaux sociaux premiers chiffres à
retenir de cette journée est de la
participation estimation à 17 heures
pour la bourgogne franche comté
elle s'élève à près de 43% 42,9 vous le
voyez précisément contre 43 12 01 au
niveau national oui c'est un peu plus
qu'en 2010 précisément 1,62 point
supplémentaire noter que les
bourguignons ont un peu plus voter que
les francs comtois 43,23 contre 40 2,14
pour cent revenons sur le scénario de ce
dimanche voyons quelles étaient les
motivations des électeurs en franche
comté et les raisons du non vote des
abstentionnistes
reportage à besançon de michel bisons et
sébastien poirier
les auteurs de besançon en début
d'après-midi un jour de promenade et
d'élections régionales
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas allés voter
non pourquoi vous ne sortez pas
concernés au niveau régional c'est pas
vraiment quelles sont les actions
prévues par dans les candidats et enfin
je suis parent parents encourent en fait
quelques heures plus tôt le matin les
bureaux de vote n'ont pas connu une
grande affluence
mais un désir très marquée d'afficher un
geste citoyen je pense que c'est un
devoir que tout citoyen doit faire
surtout pour les femmes s'étaient
accordés après est donc maintenant je
suis contente de le faire à chaque fois
lorsqu'on évoque une forte abstention
possible les votants n'oublie pas de
rappeler qu'il n'y a pas d'élection
mineurs ya des personnes qui disent que
c'est pas très important mais si c'est
aussi important que le reste
même son de cloche sur ce marché pour
voter pour le non selon tant que les
régions font beaucoup de choses si on
les abandonne cette première élection
bourgogne franche comté entraîne aussi
de nombreuses réflexions sur la nouvelle
grande région c'est la première fois
qu'il aura bourgogne franche comté et
sabu ça vous évoque quoi un gros point
d'interrogation à besançon c'est pas
sans inquiétude puisque effectivement on
va se rallier à la bourgogne
et qu'est ce qui restera à besançon
qu'est ce qui rend bourgogne y en avait
trop en france et sans eux sans
suffisamment de pouvoir par rapport aux
länder allemands avec le taux
d'abstention et les premiers résultats
les points d'interrogation devrait
encore rester nombreux ce soir a noté un
point commun des deux régions beaucoup
de communes rurales voyons ces
régionales depuis deux villages
côte-d'oriens sylvain willot et
christophe gaillard se sont notamment
rendus à gergen gergovie et bien c'est
le centre géographique de la future
grande région bourgogne franche comté où
le taux de participation définitif cette
fois est de 67% un peu plus que la
moyenne pour une franche comté regardez
le reportage gergen 128 habitants et
cent une personnes inscrites sur les
listes électorales
11h même si seulement 17 électeurs
s'étaient déplacés
le taux de participation était déjà au
dessus d'eux
moyenne régionale de plus dans ce petit
village on est visiblement pas peu fier
d'être le centre géographique de la
grande région
hier la fois des pôles des pôles urbains
qui sont extrêmement importants dijon et
besançon et c'est quand même dominé par
par une vie rurale qui qui est prégnante
est ici dans la région donc je trouve ça
me bouclé nouilles à 45 km de là autres
communes rurales brazey-en-plaine etc
1925 électeurs pour 2500 habitants
à 16 heures les deux bureaux de vote ne
désemplissent pas je trouve que par les
temps qui courent où oui c'est important
de venir voter joly effectivement même
pas que par les temps qui courent c'est
exprimer ses idées
oui c'est important pour nous c'est
normal on a le droit de mode qui folle
il faut faut s'en servir
il faut après on verra bien ici même si
la participation de ces élections
régionales n'est pas comparable à celle
d'une présidentielle pour les assesseurs
cette relative affluence est une
surprise
jusqu'il ya là je pense que les gens son
mobilier
c'est un premier tour et je pense qu'ils
se sont mobilisés je m'attendais à moins
de votants à 17h40 7,9 pour cent des
électeurs de brazey-en-plaine avait voté
un taux de participation 5 points
au-dessus de la moyenne bourgogne
franche comté
il y avait donc là des listes en course
pour ce premier tour les leaders ont
effectué leur devoir citoyen dans leur
fief à savoir besançon vitaux et
s'invite vous propose ensuite des images
du vote de ces personnalités marie-guite
dufay françois sauvadet ou encore sophie
montel tous réunis et commenté par
isabelle meunier
c'est dans une ancienne école de son
quartier de bregille que marie-guite
dufay a voté en fin de matinée
la tête de liste pour le parti
socialiste est arrivé seul plutôt
discrètement pour glisser son bulletin
nul plutôt souriante la présidente
sortante de la région n'a pour autant
pas caché une certaine inquiétude
bonne journée la journée sera longue
pour vous mais je sens j'ai le sentiment
qu'il sera encore plus longue pour moi
je pense qu'on fait monter inexorable du
front national et la gauche et la droite
ont une responsabilité
c'est effectivement perspective très
difficile à admettre à peu près à la
même heure la loi dit françois sauvadet
s'est lui rendu à la mairie de vito le
candidat de l'union de la droite a voté
en famille
petit rappel à l'ordre amusé du
scrutateurs il faut prendre au moins
deux listes en afrique enfin je crois
sobre digne responsable sans surfer sur
les peurs et on propose un nouveau
chemin voilà deux changements par
rapport à une gauche qui a beaucoup déçu
aussi
quant à la candidate du front national
s'est accompagnée de son mari qu'elle
s'est rendue à la mi journée à l'école
de musique de saint vith sophie montel
détendu en apparence dans l'attenté de
l'issue du scrutin
on est un peu comme un lion qui tourne
en cage ça va être un peu ça tu es les
heures sont les heures passer le temps
et essayer de penser à autre chose se
nettoyer un peu la tête de tout ça pour
être parfaitement comment dire dans les
starting blocks ce soir le rendez vous
est pris
fin du suspense pour ces trois candidats
dans moins d'une heure et il est 19
heures 7 à 7 heures tous les bureaux de
vote ont fermé en bourgogne franche
comté je vous rappelle le taux de
participation à 17h dans la grande
région
il s'élève à près de 43% 42,9 très
exactement 43,01 au niveau national à
noter que pour la bourgogne franche
comté c'est un peu plus élevé qu'en 2010
aux dernières régionales 1,60 deux
points de plus légèrement de son
revanche de la moyenne nationale et nous
partons pour la préfecture de dijon où
seront centralisés tous les résultats à
ce soir sur place emmanuel pinsonneault
vous avez le détail de la participation
pour chacun de nos vies département oui
alors en commençant par le département
qui a le plus voté à 17h aujourd'hui il
s'agit de l'yonne en bourgogne avec 47,1
% de participation loin devant les
autres sept points de mieux qu'en 2010
en deuxième position la côte-d'or 44 %
de participation
la haute-saône termine ce trio de tête
avec 43,7 % viennent ensuite autour de
42% le territoire de belfort 42,8 et et
la saône-et-loire 40 2,6
en sixième position le jura 41% de
participation avant dernier le doubs
40,9 et enfin en queue de peloton et
seul département encore sous la barre
des 40% à 17 heures il s'agit de la
nièvre 39,9 % de taux de participation
alors si on fait un point rapide une
comparaison avec le scrutin régional de
2010 au premier tour est toujours à la
même heure à 17 heures la participation
est en hausse très nettement dans
l'yonne et en côte d'or
hausse également mais dans une moindre
mesure en saône et loire et dans le jura
c'est stable en ce qui concerne la
nièvre participation en baisse en
revanche et surtout en franche comté
dans le doubs et jusqu'à 3 points de
moins dans le territoire de belfort et
en haute-saône
rendez vous tout à l'heure pour les
premiers résultats résultats que nous
vous donnerons à partir de 20h avec une
estimation exclusif pour france
télévision pour savoir également comment
nous avons voté dans notre région on
vient de le voir la participation est
globalement en hausse dans la bourgogne
france-comté jérémy la participation
c'est un élément déterminant dans ce
scrutin
ben oui évidemment au nom s'oriente peu
ou prou vers une un niveau d'abstention
autour de 50% un électeur sur deux donc
ne s'est pas déplacée aujourd'hui et ce
malgré les nombreux appels répétés dans
tous les partis d'ailleurs à aller voter
ces derniers jours voté pour la
république voté contre le terrorisme
pour ou contre le front national aussi
et bien finalement toutes ces leçons de
citoyenneté un peu moralisatrice n'ont
semble-t-il pas convaincu les quelques 2
millions d'électeurs de bourgogne et de
franche comté
on devrait avoir un taux d'abstention
similaire à celui des régionales
1010 une abstention supérieure donc aux
dernières élections départementales au
printemps dernier peut-être parce que
les enjeux de ces régionales ne sont pas
claires pour les citoyens surtout avec
la réforme territoriale qui a modifié
les frontières et les compétences
et puis les régions évidemment sont plus
grandes difficile peut-être de
s'identifier à cette nouvelle
collectivité
et puis nous sommes au mois de décembre
une période pas forcément propice nous
n'avions pas voter aussi tard dans
l'année
depuis 1965 ça fait un demi siècle quand
même
alors dans ce contexte de forte
abstention chaque partie doit mobiliser
d'abord son propre électorat
un dernier mot généralement la
franche-comté vote davantage que la
bourgogne cela s'est vérifié à tous les
derniers scrutins ce ne serait pas le
cas ce soir comme si la franche-comté
voulait envoyer un message n'adhéraient
pas vraiment à cette grande région ce
sera aussi l'un des éléments d analyse
des résultats ce soir
merci beaucoup à jérémie et j'en profite
pour vous donner une estimation
justement de l'abstention définitive
elle seule rai 2 49% et pour la bande à
une franche comté tout au long de cette
soirée nous serons en direct près de
chez vous à dijon besançon belfort
nevers ou encore mâcon stéphanie
bourgeot nous vous retrouvons en direct
de besançon vous êtes au kursaal de
besançon là où s'est réunie les forces
de gauche ce soir on sortait fanni
bonsoir je suis effectivement en direct
du kursaal alors pour nos
téléspectateurs bourguignons qui ne
connaissent pas le kursaal c'est d'abord
une salle de spectacle mais c'est aussi
le qg traditionnelle du parti socialiste
c'est ici que les militants se
retrouvent sitôt les dépouillements
entamées pour attendre la lecture des
résultats et pour avoir couvert
plusieurs scrutins dans cette même salle
que vous dire qu'il ya ce soir comme un
malaise et oui il dit à personne ou
presque
à cette heure ci normalement les troupes
commencent à arpenter le parquet a formé
de petits groupes à extrapoler les
tendances du premier tour et bien pas ce
soir même le bureau de vote contigüs
dans lequel je suis allé je me suis
rendu tout à l'heure il n'y a quasiment
personne alors soit le scrutin de ce
soir n'a vraiment pas réussi à
intéresser y compris que les militants
soient les militants et les têtes
d'affiché bousculé par les récents
sondages ont préféré attendre encore un
peu avant de se montrer seule cécile
prud'hommes d'europe écologie les verts
a fait une apparition assez brève ce
soir ici merci stéphanie premières
estimations 20 heures je vous le
rappelle nous restons à besançon cette
fois au qg du front national où nous
retrouvons nicolas landes à l'eau si bon
soir nicolas bonsoir en ce moment là
vous êtes et bien écoutez on est comme
vous on attend tout simplement ici les
premiers résultats des premières
estimations de 20 heures tout ça dans un
climat une ambiance assez sereine assez
détendu que ce soit chez les militants
frontistes qui sont déjà arrivés ou chez
quelques colistière de sophie montel une
atmosphère optimiste sereine finalement
logique un regard des dernières enquêtes
d'opinion qui donnait la candidate
frontiste dans le match pour remporter
ce premier tour des élections régionales
en bourgogne franche comté sophie montel
qui n'est pas encore arrivé à ici elle
est attendue dans les prochaines minutes
sophie montel qui viendra évidemment pas
c est la soirée aux côtés de son équipe
de campagne et de ses militants et qui
devrait ensuite s'exprimer une
intervention de ce film tel que l'on
attend ici aux alentours de 20h45
à tout à l'heure nicolas les
sympathisants de la liste elle est rude
et y ait eu se retrouvent ce soir à
dijon autour de leur tête de liste
françois sauvadet sur place pour france
3 des ossements
bonsoir oui au qg de campagne de
françois sauvadet ici à dijon c'est
encore très calme un parent de militants
ils n'arriveront qu'à partir de 19h30
tous les sympathisants de la droite de
bourgogne franche comté et vont se
rassembler pour savoir à quelle place et
à quel score arrivera à la liste
conduite par françois sauvadet liste
donc eu des i l est républicain
ce matin le candidat à voter dans son
village de vitteaux en côte d'or
il nous a confié aborder ce premier tour
des élections régionales avec confiance
et responsabilité
tout en reconnaissant la grande
incertitude qui plane sur les résultats
de ce soir un flou entretenu d'ailleurs
par les récents sondages contradictoires
ces derniers jours ce soir françois
sauvadet arrivera à sa permanence
dijonnaise aux alentours de 20h30
et il livrera sa première réaction aux
sympathisants ou militants réunis ici à
21h15
voilà nos journalistes que nous
retrouverons en direct bien évidemment
tout au long de cette soirée je me
tourne vers vous lilian only lyon ce
scrutin est très particulier il est
inédit on l'a dit d'abord parce que
c'est la première fois qu'on va voter
pour la bourgogne france comté mais
aussi pour le contexte très particulier
dans lequel il intervient sur le
principal élément de sélection c'est
bien sûr les attentats qui ont largement
changé la donne et plus profondément
qu'on ne le croient ils ont totalement
pris au dépourvu des listes de droite
qui faisait campagne sur le
mécontentement et les mauvais résultats
de l'exécutif
l'image nouvelles du gouvernement face
aux événements a nettement affaibli
l'argumentaire pendant que dans le même
temps le contexte de peur et
d'inquiétude profitait au front national
qui du coup peuvent virer en tête au
premier tour en bourgogne franche comté
ce que les sondages ne disait pas par
exemple à la sortie de l'été mais comme
au billard le coup et à deux bandes car
cette poussée du front national dans les
sondages peut contribuer aussi à une
mobilisation plus forte des électeurs de
gauche très absent lors des derniers
scrutins et le dernier scrutin justement
les départementales c'est un des
éléments du contexte à droite a
largement gagné en termes de sièges mais
si on cumule nos deux régions premier
tour la droite n'avait qu'un demi points
d'avance et la lecture d'un résultat qui
disait que les français voulaient plus
de droite peut être battue en brèche par
la très forte abstention des électeurs
de gauche déçus par l'action du
gouvernement cette lecture troubles et
des départementales explique hocine
campagne sans relief accentué à droite
par la guerre interne juppé sarkozy
et puis il ya aussi bien sûr l'effet de
la fusion on en parlait ce jérémy disait
avec l'abstention et l'énorme difficulté
à faire campagne dans huit départements
et surtout sur deux régions différentes
même si elles sont voisines
une franche comté plus à droite sur les
derniers scrutins avec un front national
plus haut et surtout avec une identité
plus forte qu'une
bonnieux plus ancré à gauche comment
parler à tout le monde
personne n'y est vraiment arrivé il faut
le dire mais c'est plus facile pour ceux
qui ont décliné les idées nationales
plus qu'un vrai programme régional
ce sera aussi une des clés de ce scrutin
un des scrutins les plus incertains
qu'on ait vu depuis très longtemps dans
la région et on compte sur vous pour
commenter tout ça tout au long de la
soirée merci beaucoup lilian allez on va
retrouver également à besançon notre
journaliste catherine aime dire et
catherine bonsoir il y aura beaucoup
d'invités aussi du côté de besançon
avant côté ce soir
oui bonsoir aux dons soir à tous vos soi
route vous soir à tous
en effet pour le moment je suis seul
mais ça va pas durer nous attendons en
effet nombreux invités ici sur le
plateau du studio de besançon comme par
exemple eric alauzet le député d'europe
écologie les verts du doubs nous
attendons aussi de nice au maire
conseiller régional sortant premier vice
président socialiste du conseil régional
de franche comté ou encore le communiste
christophe lime l'écologiste du jura
brigitte monnet et puis à la le tailleur
chevènementiste du territoire de belfort
et puis et puis nous attendons sophie
montel députée européenne front national
c'est la seule tête de liste aux
régionales qui est resté sur ses terres
à besançon donc nous la recevrons au
moment où nous aurons des résultats
vraiment définitif
elle pourra réagir à ce moment là et
puis nous pourrons également avec l
envisager déjà le deuxième tour dès
dimanche prochain
merci katrina tout à leur autre endroit
où nous avons voulu vivre ce premier
tour c'est m
en haute-saône vanessa hirson vous êtes
dans la salle de dépouillement de
l'amérique ce week-end où les raisons du
choix de cette commune
effectivement nous sommes à peine une
petite commune de haute saône 1900
habitants alors pourquoi peine parce que
nous sommes au carrefour de la bourgogne
et de la franche comté pour mieux vous
situer nous sommes seulement à 100
mètres du jura à sept kilomètres de la
côte d'or et 15 km du doubs alors les
habitants de perm se sont déplacés en
nombre aujourd'hui pour voter ils sont
ainsi près de 63% à s'être déplacés mais
s'ils ont voté c'est d'abord par un acte
par acte de citoyenneté car la plupart
des personnes interrogées tout à l'heure
m'expliquer
je cite qu'il ne comprenait pas ce
rapprochement que ça ne voulait rien
dire qu'il votait juste part de voir une
ancienne professeur
d'histoire-géographie expliqué que la
bourgogne et la franche comté avait deux
histoire totalement différente et que à
l'avenir selon elle ce serait difficile
entre la bourgogne et la franche comté
entre dijon et besançon mais elle a
quand même tenu à venir voter merci
beaucoup vanessa et la bourgogne et la
franche-comté et bien sans sur les
réseaux sociaux ce soir on est avec elsa
poursuivre tout ça et autres c'est
plutôt calme pour le moment ça gazouille
très peu je vous propose du coup de
découvrir quelques instantanés de la
journée l'après midi foot vous allez le
voir 2 christophe grudler le candidat du
modem qui a écrit ce message en début
d'après midi en route pour le stade
bonal sochaux nancy c'était la coupe de
france sochaux qui s'est d'ailleurs
qualifié
du côté de la côte d'or ce sont nos
confrères du bien public qui ont posté
cette photo ac lancé le président
sortant du conseil régional de bourgogne
françois patriat est venu voter c'était
d'ailleurs très tôt ce matin
sinon quelques réactions de personnages
politiques mais finalement très peu pour
le moment vous allez voir celle d'alain
houpert le sénateur de droite de côte
d'ans réflexion du jour il nous la livre
le jour où voter ne sera plus un droit
nous regretterons l'époque où c'était un
devoir
julien houde au louis lui dans l'yonne
nous poste sa citation sa pensée ne faut
pas de signes de mais il faut réussir
ces signes et napoléon à quelques jours
après l'anniversaire d'austerlitz pour
finir un petit clin d'oeil à mon voisin
de gauche je remonte jérémy chevreuil
qui a pris le train cet après midi pour
venir ici et dans le train vous voyez
c'est est un ter
il est tombé sur un article où il est
écrit la burgenland on va voir c'est le
cas chez soi merci beaucoup à aller en
plus de regarder bien la télévision vous
pouvez également suivre toute cette
soirée sur internet et internet
justement eh bien on va retrouver la
cellule web avec sophie courageot notre
pilote web qui est du côté de la
rédaction de besançon qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir retrouver sur la toile sophie
dodémont soir rodez bien écouté depuis
quelques minutes et les sites internet
de france 3 bourgogne et franche comté
sont passés en mode direct minute par
minute un fils en fonte ou que vous
allez pouvoir suivre toute la soirée en
fil info vous trouvez actuellement est
bien le meilleur des tweets de nos deux
régions
elle les photos de nos équipes de
reportages sur le terrain
et puis un des éléments de décryptage
bien sûr pour comprendre ce scrutin tout
cela en attendant les résultats tout à
l'heure une seule adresse aux de france
3 point fr après il vous faut qu'on
vient de choisir direction à la franche
comté ou direction la bourgogne
merci sophy à tout à l'heure pour le
résultat 20h premières estimations sur
france 3 et oui des estimations
excessive surtout soyez avec nous dès
20h15 à tout à l'heure